After being
so reticent yourself
to speak about any of this publi
and holding it within
you for pretty much half, half a
50 years what made you want to c
in this way on this topic now?
Yeah, I don't think I do.
I feel like I didn't have a choi
I think.
I think that's part of the probl
Holding it in for I'm 55.
My dad died when I was ten,
and I don't think I spoke about
very much, much of my life
because it was so painful.
And my brother, the death of my
nanny from Alzheimer's,
who was a mother figure to me.
So those were things I kept.
I mean,
they changed the course of my li
They changed the person that I
started out being.
And yet,
like so many people,
I found it hard to talk about it
Without.
It just seemed so overwhelming
that to even broach
it would be cataclysmic.
And I started
as I started
going through my mom's
things after she died three year
As you said, of the grand old ag
I felt very alone in that proces
And I realized and I started rec
making recordings on my
phone just to talk myself.
It's something I do.
I just narrate it
like a correspondent does.
It helps me through things.
It's something I read.
Victor Frankl did
in his book Man's Search for Mea
He talks about doing that
in concentration camps and sort
narrating himself through experi
to kind of have a distance from
and be able to kind of understan
And I started doing that,
and I didn't think to make it a
it was just something for me.
But then I realized this
is this universal thing
that everybody will go
through the things of their pare
or their loved ones who have die
And I didn't really see
anything out there about it,
and no one really talks about it
And I just decided
to kind of put it out there.
And I've been really just stunne
by it, by the response.
So I'm going to get into that
in a moment.
You just raised the concept
of a correspondent recording exp
and trying to deal like that.
And I also was quite moved to fi
when you were much younger,
you actually went to the war zon
and we met in many of them
Somalia, Bosnia, wherever.
But that was almost
as as a as a weapon to to try to
to try to
protect yourself against
or to run away from,
I guess, these feelings.
I think it was actually to run t
I couldn't talk about these thin
but I wanted to surround myself.
I wanted to be places
where the pain I was feeling
inside was matched.
So emotional.
I talked about the the pain I wa
inside was matched by the pain o
And I felt
I understood some of these place
I mean, not to compare
my little emotions with
what was happening in Sarajevo o
you know, Somalia or Rwanda or a
But but I understood
I wanted to be around places
I want to be in places
where the language of loss was s
And I wanted to learn from other
how they survived
because I wanted to know
how I would survive
And it is really
I mean, it's really profound.
And what I want to do actually
before asking you
another question,
is play a soundbite of your moth
Gloria Vanderbilt,
who had lost her husband,
who had lost her son to suicide,
who was actually there
when when your brother
actually took his own life.
So we can talk about it afterwar
But but but she told Larry King
about the process about you know
the process
when when a grieving caller phon
I think if you can just
go over it again and again and a
and this is the image that I use
of breaking through the glass ru
because I used to be really
a very reserved person
that didn't show my feelings.
And when Carter Cooper died,
it was like breaking through thi
and communicating
with everybody in the world beca
are all connected
That's amazing.
Did she talk
to you about all of that at that
I absolutely.
My mom was
my mom
had experienced great losses
throughout her life,
and that really shaped
the course of her life.
From the time
she was little child,
she was removed
from the custody of her mother
and her beloved nanny
by the courts in New York
and a famous custody battle
at the height of the Depression.
And so she spent her life
replaying and rethinking and com
to try to understand the losses
she had experienced.
And so
she was able to talk about it wi
I just wasn't
and I wasn't able to listen.
But I
you know,
she would try to keep
my father's name alive in our ho
She would tell stories about him
It for me was so painful.
It was like the third rail.
It was something I couldn't touc
I would listen
but I couldn't really break out
to, you
know, toward the end of her life
she and I had very deep conversa
and I was
we connected
and we had nothing left
unsaid between us by the time.
But when I was young,
it was particularly hard for me.
And it is
unbelievable, really.
It is hard to imagine what you f
Your father died of a heart,
a heart disease when you were te
But but you say in the podcast
that you weren't
even allowed really
to visit him in the hospital.
Children weren't
allowed in the in the in the ICU
And then and then your
your brother
when you were 21, he was 23 left
from the 14th floor
apartment of the building.
And your mother
was there when it happened.
Yeah.
You're now processing.
Yeah. And tried to stop him.
Was she able to process it herse
You know that I that weren't pro
I don't you know, it's
a very it's a word we hear a lot
I'm not exactly sure what it mea
I mean she relooked at constantl
she replayed it in her head
every single day of her life
for the rest of her life.
And she never I mean, it is,
it is one of the terrible things
about suicide
for anybody out there
whose experience at the death
of a loved one through suicide,
there's the questions of
why did somebody do this
and did they even know why
they were doing it?
And the feelings of, you know, d
One of the things about suicide
is you're left.
It's difficult to remember the w
somebody live their life.
You're left
with remembering very much
and stuck in your mind
how they ended their life.
And I have this conversation
in the podcast with a guy named
Miller who also lost his sister
You end up kind
of, at least in my case, wonderi
did I even really know my brothe
because I didn't know
he was going to do this.
And if I didn't know that,
how did I even know really who
who he was?
But my mom,
you know, until the day she died
she would out of the blue say to
you know,
maybe if I had, you know, grabbe
from the fireplace and hit,
you know, Carter,
it would have knocked him out.
And maybe that would have stoppe
I could have stopped him
and from going to the balcony.
And so she she
you know, she could never get to
where she could accept the death
But but she got to a place
where she could continue to live
you know, and,
you know, you and I have
spent our lives
going to places
and asking questions
and trying to understand
why things happen.
And for me,
part of that has been to come to
And, you know, you were famously
you know, your coverage in Bosni
You can ask somebody
why the whys of things
till you're blue in the face
and some things no answer they g
Who's going to make sense of
why somebody is committing genoc
or why somebody is committing
great brutality or another?
And sometimes you have to live,
get to a place
where you can live without a lie
And that's the way it is.
I think for me,
at least in the wake
of my brother's suicide,
getting to a place
where I could live in a world wh
sometimes there isn't a lot
that that
that is really an important thin
you just said.
Really, because everybody wants
to their questions.
But sometimes they just they jus
You have also experienced an amo
I mean, I laughed and cried thro
So did you
I mean,
there were interviews that you d
with some of
some of your guests on this podc
that also had, you know,
the wry
side, the human that some
sometimes humorous side.
And that particularly
with Stephen Colbert, who experi
also an unspeakable tragedy
when he was little,
he lost his father and two broth
in a plane crash.
You you talk to them,
but you also love this quote by
Tolkien that he brought up to yo
And it was it was it was also ve
very profound.
Do you know which one I mean?
Yeah. Yeah. You tell.
Absolutely.
Tolkien wrote in a letter and St
Colbert told me about this
three years ago
when I first talked to him
right after my mom died,
and Tolkien wrote to somebody sa
what of God's punishments or not
Yes.
Or what punishment of God is not
And when I
when I read that, I was stunned
I read that Stephen had said tha
And I
and I'm still stunned
by this idea
that you can become grateful wel
for the thing
you most wish had never happened
And how how can you get to that
and can you really get to that p
And what does that even mean?
To be grateful
for the worst thing
that has ever happened to you?
And what Stephen will say
and does say,
and I've come closer to that sin
is it you
it's not that you wanted
this thing to happen
or that you ever wish had happen
but it has made you the person y
And if you want to be
the most human being, you can be
you have to experience loss.
You have to be grateful for ever
You can't just pick and choose
what you're grateful for.
If you if you want to be a human
And this is something that we al
we all go through this
and it makes you and you're grea
what you're grateful for,
not as the death of your loved o
but for what it
it it is the opportunity
that it gives you to break throu
what my mom call that sort of th
feeling or that bubble
or to to be connected
to everybody around you
and to understand
that vulnerability and connect
with people at the most basic,
deepest level.
And that is what grief has done
That is what the deaths of my fa
and brother and mother
and many have done for me.
They have allowed
me, though
it's difficult for me still,
but they have allowed me to
to connect with people
in the darkest of moments in the
It really is remarkable.
It's great to talk to you.
The series is incredible.
And really,
it's just amazing that you did i
Thank you, Anderson.
Thank you, Christiane.